when I first started climbing I was so
bad I was so terrible so slow I'd tear
my skin up all the time it was like how
the heck are we gonna go and do Mount
Kilimanjaro
three words I don't know those three
words three of the most important words
in my life
all discoveries happen from I don't know
[Music]
my name is Kyle Maynard and I have an
extremely hard time saying what it is
exactly that I do I've been an athlete
my entire life
football to wrestling to weightlifting
and Brazilian jiu-jitsu and now most
recently taking on climbing some of the
highest mountains in the world I was
born with congenital amputation so
basically means my arms and at the
elbows my legs ended the knees you know
I think some people who they look at me
and maybe even feel sorry for me but
really truthfully my life doesn't look a
whole lot different than yours
you know I type on my computer the same
way you know use my phone just like
anybody else I'm on bumble like anybody
any other single person my age we got a
match my first experience with climbing
really anything of significance was in a
CrossFit competition in 2010 the first
workout was you had to do a
thousand-meter row in this rowing
machine in a sprint up Stone Mountain
everybody else did it maybe 25 minutes
it took me an hour and 46 minutes at
oral a skin up on my arms but I got to
the top and I was like wow this is
breathtakingly beautiful and I told my
friend that night I said I want to climb
Mount Kilimanjaro I don't know if I can
I don't know if I can't but I do know
that I want to try to figure it out I
want to go and find a way and and get up
there
there were ton of challenges with
getting into climbing and the biggest
one was the gear I literally started
with bath towels duct-taped to my arms
to my feet I couldn't go to the store
and buy a typical pair of shoes we had
to come up with a unique solution
now to climb I use a carbon fiber
special custom shoe I use those to bear
crawl up Kilimanjaro then me my team we
took on climbing Mount Aconcagua the
highest peak in South America I felt my
body was like in full shutdown mode
and it was brutal at moments but it was
breathtakingly beautiful at the top of
that mountain you know you can almost
kind of make out and see like the
curvature of the earth I mean it was
just a moment I'll never forget the
reasons I climb aren't that different
from other people 95% of it does suck
I'm staring at the dirt I'm not even
able to go and talk to my friends and
see the beautiful views unless I stop
and sit down and look but that 5% that
doesn't suck it's amazing you do in a
place that there's no way my wheelchair
could have brought me there that's what
I love I'm not trying to live to be a
thousand like I want to want to go out
there and have my life means something
when I've gotten down and I've looked at
the mountain and I see what we've
achieved it's like wow maybe that was a
really bad idea that we were there but
it was beautiful
[Music]